المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه في غزه ادت حتى
اللحظه الى استشهاد 310 من الكوادر الصحيه
وتدمير 102 سياره اسعاف وخروجها بالكامل
عن الخدمه كما ادت الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه
الى استهداف
138 مؤسسه صحيه واخراج 22 مستشفى عن
الخدمه وكذلك 52 مركز للرعايه الاوليه خرج
عن الخدمه
تماما اضافه الى اننا لازلنا نؤكد بان
الاليه المتبعه في مغادره الجرحى للعلاج
بالخارج يستخدمها الا الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
سلاح في يده لقتل الجرحى ونطالب الجهات
المعنيه بتوفير اليه فاعله لانقاذ حياه
الجرحى لان ما خرج حتى اللحظه عبر بوابه
معبر رفح البري اقل من 1% من حجم الاصابات
الموجوده في قطاع غزه ونحن بحاجه
ما الى مغادره 5000 جريح دفعه واحده و الى
خارج قطاع غزه من اجل انقاذ حياتهم ولدينا
الالاف الاخرى التي تحتاج الى جدوله وخروج
ومتابعه لخروجهم الى خارج القطاع من اجل
انقاذ حياتهم والقائمه تطول لان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لازال يرتكب مجازر واباده
جماعيه في قطاع غزه
مخلفا المئات من الجرحى بعد كل مجزره
يرتكبها في قطاع غزه كما ان استمرار نفاذ
تطعيمات الاطفال في قطاع غزه يفاقم الوضع
الصحي للاطفال المواليد وخاصه في مراكز
النزوح ونطالب الجهات المعنيه بالعمل
الفوري على توفيرها كما ان الوضع الصحي
والانساني في مراكز واماكن الايواء كارثي
وغير انساني على الاطلاق نتيجه انتشار
الاوبئه والامراض المعد وسوء التغذيه وقله
مياه الشرب والنظافه الشخصيه وعدم توفر
الرعايه الصحيه كما ان الطواقم الصحيه
رصدت اصابه 350 الف نازح بالامراض المعديه
في مراكز الايواء وهذا العدد هو العدد
الذي استطاع فقط الوصول الى المراكز
الصحيه ولا يعكس اطلاقا الحجم الكلي
للمصابين في مراكز الايواء ون اعتقد انهم
بمئات الالاف في داخل مراكز الايواء
وبالتالي نحذر من كارثه انسانيه وصحيه في
داخل هذه
المراكز كما نطالب المؤسسات الامميه
بالعمل على توفير المقومات المعيشيه
والرعايه الصحيه في مراكز الايواء لاكثر
من 700000 طفل و5000 سيده حامل و350 مريض
مزمن منهم 1100 مريض بالفشل الكلوي
يحتاجون الى غسيل الكلى وكذلك الاف الجرحى
الذين يحتاجون الى متابعه سر متابعه
لحالاتهم المعقده كما نطالب شركاء العمل
الصحي الى اقامه نقاط طبيه وعيادات متنقله
لتوفير الرعايه الصحيه للنازحين في اماكن
الاواء المنتشره غرب محافظه خانيونس وغرب
محافظه رفح كما ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
نؤكد مجددا على انه يستخدم المساعدات
الطبيه كما قلت سلاح لقتل الجرحى في
المستشفيات وتسبب بشلل قدرات المنظومه
الصحيه من خلال التحكم في حجم ونوعيه
ومسار المساعدات الطبيه ومنع وصولها
للشمال ونطالب بتوفير ممر انساني امن يسمح
بتدفق الامدادات الطبيه والوقود ووصولها
لكافه مستشفيات قطاع غزه كما نطالب
المؤسسات الدوليه بالتدخل العاجل لتوفير
الاحتياجات الدوائيه والوقود باعاده تشغيل
مجمع الشفاء الطبي بشكل عاجل لانه الامل
الوحيد الان للجرحى والمرضى والسيدات
الحوامل والاطفال بعد خروج مستشفيات شمال
قطاع غزه عن الخدمه كما نطالب كافه الدول
والمؤسسات الدوليه باقامه مستشفيات
ميدانيه في شمال قطاع غزه لانقاذ الجرحى
والمرضى رحم الله شهدائنا وشفى الله
جرحانا وحمى الله شعبنا من هذا العدوان
والمحتل الغاصب والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته